going broad is the slowest game but the
most sustainable game so winning on
YouTube for example it's the it's the
hardest to get going because people
don't know who you are yet you got to
build your brand you got to get great
message front of the camera get
comfortable all that kind of stuff it
just takes time to build the brand and a
lot of people they quit along the way
because for that to become something
that's financially feasible to support
you most people quit because they need
to pay the bills so that's why figuring
out like how can we make money while
we're building the brand is a lot more
critical so you can do it that I'm just
going to do coaching one-on-one and keep
my 15 people or 20 people whatever is
sustainable inside here four hours a day
and then you have two hours to do other
stuff right build the brand or you can
go coaching group and then build the
brand the more financial resources you
have the more you can invest in team to
do a lot of the stuff to help you more
it's you trying to figure everything
else out everything's going to go slower
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe Nation hey seven Carmichael and
I make these videos because running the
business heart and waking up every day
and getting to work when you're all by
yourself is hard and the thing that
saved me that continues to inspire me
motivate me give me hope inspiration
ideas is looking at the stories of
people who've done a lot more than me
and I learned strategies I get
motivation and it gets me to believe in
myself to go off and attack the day and
so I hope this video inspires you to do
the same as well so today let's learn
from me and my team's take on my top 10
rules of success enjoy
rule number two is have self-awareness I
was curious if you like found yourself
taking on personality traits of like
recklessness like you went way far on
the other side and like discernment was
starting to get grayed the lines were
starting to get blurred has any of that
ever crept into like I know I don't want
to live with regret so I'm going to go
all in on the other side I don't think
that happens okay you know there's
planners and doers and the planners need
to do more and the doers need to plan
more
but it's very rare that a planner just
becomes a doer and stops planning
yeah right it says people who just plan
things for years and then they still
don't do anything and then as people
just take action but they're like all
over the place and tomorrow's a
different action the next season and
there's no plan or strategy and they end
up just running around in circles tons
of action but not moving anywhere you're
just running in a circle
and so I think it's it's uh I haven't
really seen people move from one
category to the other but whatever
category you're in you need more of that
other thing people ask me about humility
is like well you're humble and all this
stuff it's like okay well I need more
bravado I would be doing my my mission
more service if I had a little more
bravado and ego and look at me and chest
thumping it's taken me a long time to
come out of my shell and even say yes to
any interview like I've done enough of
these now but if this was 10 years ago I
would have said no I would have said no
Nicholas like or what are your questions
I need to know everything you're going
to ask me because I'd be afraid of
letting you down or letting your your
show down and so I think whatever those
personality traits are that you have I
haven't seen people completely move to
the other side and if anything you need
more of that in your life so I I would
think most people need more of the let's
not live with regret because most people
live with regret
and there's some few crazy people might
have a gene missing or something who
like are just insanely Reckless and
don't care and maybe they need a little
more caution and planning and strategy
you know so it's it's the self-awareness
to know what you need most yeah
self-awareness definitely helps rule
number three is believe what is your
superpower
what is my superpower yeah
believe him in people yeah
yeah you know I think whatever the thing
is that um you know what's my biggest
Kryptonite
believing in myself
you know like the thing the thing that
you want to give to the world is also
the thing that you need the most too
so you know people say well you're the
believe guy how do you not believe in
yourself well I believe in myself to get
here to do everything that I've done
it's it's the next step
the next level of Evan Carmichael is on
the other side of even more belief and
as I learn and improve and grow and
figure out some new strategies I'm going
to then share it with my audience as
well rule number four develop an
interest in AI the AI tools are
incredible
yeah so like if you're not interested in
Ai and you're not applying it to your
business and not following along you're
you're losing like you need everybody
needs to figure out AI in their business
100 percent
it's getting better by Leaps and Bounds
like every week there's some new tool
there's some new thing you can do it's
crazy we've already uh accidentally
posted a video of me on my channel my
wife thought it was me and she posted it
to my Instagram and it wasn't me it
wasn't my video it wasn't my voice it
wasn't my script and my team was just
playing around with it and sent it to us
as a hey here's a demo and she thought
it was something that needed to be
posted so she posted it
what already and like it's only gonna
get
worse and crazier and more authentic and
more real like I could watch and say
that's not me but I thought there's no
way like people will know but if it
fooled my wife already then it's gonna
fool
everybody wow right and what and what's
that software or it was they put
everything together from different AIS
Le it was different just the video Ai
and then there's a script AI as it was
like GPT to write the video like to
write the script like use write a script
about belief in the voice of Evan
Carmichael and then it pop something up
right
um and then 11 labs to train the audio
to actually have it sound like me and
I've trained my voice right so we've
done the recordings and have all the
samples so we've trained my voice yet
but I'm playing with it like you have to
you have to play with it so train my
voice as a video one I don't remember
which we're playing with around a bunch
of video tools I don't remember which
video tool we use to make it happen
um but yeah like it it we posted it
and wow then I had to go back and say oh
this is this is AI Evan you know
but it's only better but this is where
nfts come in this is where yeah why it's
so valuable because that's that still
requires a lot of it's It's GPT plus 11
Labs plus whatever video tool you know
then to make it into an Instagram video
like it's a lot of it's a lot of mess to
figure all that out that's got all gonna
go away
just like entities it's hard to set up a
wallet and figure out ethereum and buy
it and get it like it's it's it's hard
but that's gonna all go away that's
going to be the default right it's going
to be easy in the future to make that
happen also to make sure you're actually
taking action after watching this video
I've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is establish
emotional connections I've heard you
discuss that 80 of the content system is
getting people to have an emotional
reaction to what you create what
strategies do you have in place to
ensure your audience has an emotional
connection with your content you need to
have an emotional connection to the
content so you do an interview like how
many of these have you done on this
channel we're approaching
171 171 about 170 171 interviews okay so
like if you're gonna do interviews you
better like doing interviews yeah amen
because
you're gonna be 171 interviews in and
then hate your life so for people like
I'm going to start a podcast cool but
you better like talking to people
even if you're like I'm introverted I'm
shy it's not natural or normal but I
like serving and so this is one of the
ways to do it but if you don't if you're
doing it just as a strategy You're Gonna
Lose You have to actually be curious
about people and then you have to bring
on guests who you actually care about
right so if you brought on a guest who
like you love their story and you love
something that they've done
then that's gonna light you up and if it
lights you up it'll light up the
audience versus if they're on
just for a strategy you know if it's
like I'm gonna bring on somebody to talk
about
passive income because it's trending but
like you don't care about passive income
right then it's gonna be the most boring
and maybe you do I don't know but it'd
be the most boring interview you know of
all time and so the key is is making
content that you deeply connect with
that you get super excited by and your
energy will create energy for the people
watching like oh my God this guy's so
excited by it I'm going to get into it
too rule number six is focus on learning
I love how fascinated you are to just
learn and take what you like from
different people and then apply it and
so forth and it's you'll never not that
you need to worry about it but you'll
never get stale or dull or repeat
yourself too much because you're
constantly learning and applying and
then giving back it's awesome
well thank you I mean there's a lot in
there appreciate it
um really I'm just making videos and
content and having guests on and being
guests on shows that
that I'm curious about you know I love
being on with you like you came to me
through Dave and Dave's like hey I got
this new guy and work with Craig
can you hop on an IG live together right
I didn't know who you were but it's Dave
so like okay happy to do it right and
then like we're back for round two
because round one was so good right and
so
I'm not a strategic of
uh I need to do this person because it's
gonna help me grow my channel it's more
what what do I want to learn if I just
wanted to grow I should go negative
if I did the top 10 stupidest things
Kanye has said
that would that'd be fire people would
love that stuff right people but I'm
trying to spread it would make me feel
gross because I want to create optimism
and belief and hope for people rule
number seven is study nfts we often
judge ideas too early
you look at the nft market right nfts
are going to the moon it's amazing you
know board day crypto Punk let's go like
wag me you know all of this right uh and
then you know that was that was the that
was the Opium at the time and now it
crashed and you know a lot of people are
negative but it's this isn't the final
nfts are are gonna happen everybody will
have a wallet everybody will have it
whether we even call them nfts or
something else in the future like the
blockchain is undeniable it will happen
everything will be on the blockchain
everything everything we do will be on
the blockchain
so what we see right now as much as this
pessimism and negativity this is not the
final thing and so I see I look at the
same thing with the verification system
they're looking for ways to make money
and they're looking for ways to combat a
lot of the
the fake and the the company yeah but
this me this is not an elegant solution
either what they've done is not elegant
and so it will be fixed and somebody
will fix it whether it's whether it's
Instagram whether it's tick tock whether
it's Elon Musk again whether it's some
new social media site that pops up comes
out of nowhere you know whether it's
look at how quickly GPT came out of
nowhere
and just popped hard like maybe that's
the next social network that pops hard
and figures out verification as well so
it's
we're just I don't want to judge is it
great no but I'm also judging an
unfinished product it's like if you gave
me your book that's half written and
said Andre is like this is not very good
well it's half written so we can't judge
you something else will come from it I
don't know who solves the problem but
somebody will solve that problem rule
number eight is learn to deal with
criticisms give us a definition of what
is a little man and and how you define
that and maybe how you manage to you
know ignore it defy it as you were
growing your business and your Channel
sure so the little man is the hater in
your life it's the person who's telling
you that you can't do it pointing out
all the reasons why your next podcast is
not going to work or your big book or
whatever your dream is all the reasons
why it's not going to work out and often
those are people those are real people
in our lives maybe it's our parents our
friends our guidance counselor our boss
you know people in our community and
often it's ourselves You Know The Enemy
is is the end of me right like you are
your own enemy
um and so oftentimes we have great big
ideas that we're excited by and then how
often do we talk ourselves down from
those big Ideas after you sleep on it
and the next day you wake up the guy I
can't do that I'm yeah two nobody will
listen to me on but before even tell
anybody else it's your your own inner
little man that is holding you back so
that's the little man and and rule
number seven it's there because it's one
of the most consistent things that come
up with big entrepreneurs and dreamers
you're doing something that is crazy
That is bull that has never been done
before and whenever you do that you know
if you're a change maker you're doing
things that have never been done before
and so you're gonna get criticism you're
gonna get heat both from the outside
world and the inside world and so the
two things that I find really help me
personally with that one is just being
around people who have to deal with
criticism a lot and see how they react I
think is valuable I think as an example
if you want to get more confident
better than reading a book on eight ways
to get more confident start hanging
around confident people if you do that
their mindsets their beliefs their
attitudes will rub off on you like if
you want to if you want to be a change
maker better than just downloading some
PDF with eight different ways on how to
be a change maker hanging around Jay
like he is a change maker just by
hanging out
regardless of what he
what he's fired some change within you
and the more you hang around Jay and
guys like Jay the more you listen to
this podcast then the more you're going
to just be willed into making change for
yourself just like if you're hanging
around negative people all day long
you're going to become negative you're
going to complain more or if you're
hanging around big game changing People
you're gonna start gravitating towards
that right it's the concept of you are
your your best closest friends around
you right right right right so so that's
one so if you want to avoid the little
manner or learn how to ignore them then
you need to be around people who are
dealing with big things and dealing with
criticism and chances are those aren't
currently the people in your life there
there are other people so for me that's
where I get it from the book I get it
from the videos seeing how somebody
reacts to criticism say huh that's
interesting I would have I would have
felt I would have taken that more
critically or I would have been hurt by
that and seen how they do it if you do
that consistently they'll rub off on you
rule number nine is pay attention to
your energy try to pay attention to the
micro moments where you're feeling
like something's not great so we had our
first session on Instagram live it was
great you know your team messages me for
round two like yeah let's go round two
with Craig down right
but if you have somebody else if
somebody on your team who is bringing
you down for one day it's like huh okay
that's interesting
if it happens the second day or second
week like maybe it's worth talking and
see what's going on if it keeps
happening like maybe that person
shouldn't be in your life yeah
and so it's constantly paying attention
to the things that give you energy and
take away it's really just about energy
management than anything else you're
talking about balance like pay attention
to your energy and do more of the things
and be around more of the people that
give you energy and my work gives me
energy I'm I'm leaving with more energy
with this interview than I came in scene
right so like this didn't deplete me it
filled me out this is great thank you
absolutely and like we want to strive to
do more things that give us energy as
opposed to the plaint and that applies
to your relationships your work your
sleep your your Fitness routine your
food all of it does it give you more
energy or does it take away animal
number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is take action how
long were you thinking about inviting me
on before you invited me on
um
it's a great question I've been mulling
on it for a long time this is our mutual
connection I interviewed Kevin Palmieri
okay who is from The Next Level
University and you've been on their show
twice okay so since I got in contact
with him and he spoke so highly of you
that's how long so six months seven
months I mean I don't think I even
looked at your Channel or what you're
about or whatever it's just your message
and I decided so I would have said yes
seven months ago right exactly right
it's about taking action jumping right
into it so but so you never know like
this is this is the thing and whether
it's as big as I might regret this in
the future if I don't if I don't say yes
or ask or or whatever it's also just the
mulling things over now again kudos to
you for then deciding to do it because a
lot of people then never do it they
never reach out they never ask they
never start that business they never
write the book they never whatever the
thing is that they want to do
a lot of people seven months later have
already told themselves why they can't
do that thing and so you then you know
congratulations like you did it and here
we are and I might have said no or I
might have ignored you or said I hate
anybody named Nicholas like you never
know you never know when you send
something what the reaction is going to
be
happiness comes down to fulfillment
versus excitement when people ask me hey
Evan how do you how do you define
happiness it's one of the most common
questions I get asked when I'm doing
interviews and podcasts and such what
does happiness look like to you what
happiness
is fulfillment and excitement
because it's very interesting word so
let's break it down
film it is feeling like what you do
matters
you're happy when you feel like what you
do matters you're happy when you feel
like you wake up today and today is
gonna matter this is what we all want we
all want to feel like what we're gonna
do today is going to have an impact on
somebody else's life we are all built to
serve you want to feel important to
somebody else not just from a ego
perspective that oh I matter and I'm
important but in a way that you
contributed to somebody else's life
we're all connected we want to feel
connected we want to feel like this is
going to matter today that this video
that I make for you even though I'm here
just in the car by myself well Lena's
actually Nina's back there hello Nina
even though I'm just here filming by
myself in the car I want to feel like
this video is touching somebody touching
you that you guys are watching it and
hopefully the message here is going to
be inspiring and helpful to you in some
way we all want that that's fulfillment
right if you wake up too many days in a
row and you feel like today doesn't
matter nobody cares if I show up nobody
cares if I do a good job or not nobody
cares that's a fast path to depression
and worst case suicide right that's
where a lot of people unfortunately are
living right now they don't feel like
they matter they're not happy because
there's no fulfillment
they're not happy because they feel like
they don't matter to anybody
so that's fulfillment the other side of
happiness is excitement you're happy
when you feel like you're doing
something new you're happy when you get
to try something new you get to have fun
you get to do something that hasn't been
done before you're you're you're going
out of your comfort zone or you're
you're having this quick hit right I
mean it could be anything from I'm
excited to have my coffee yeah I'm
excited to have my Starbucks you know
when we go once a week to film we get a
Starbucks put some cream in and I'm
excited for the taste right you could be
excited for that donor that meal you
know it may not even be good for you the
Donut's not good for you but you're
still excited to have it because it
tastes so good you're chasing this
little momentary high or you could be
excited to go on that vacation you're
excited just something new this it's a
it's a moment in time
it's the little it's the candy it's the
sweets
right and it's the sweets of life it's
not sustainable but it's not designed to
be sustainable
it's these little moments in time that
make us happy and that's true too but
that's why it's excitement
jumping from an airplane you know is
exciting
it's not sustainable you're not gonna
show up every day and and fall from the
airplane all day long right and so I
think where a lot of people struggle a
lot of entrepreneurs especially is we're
chasing the excitement only you're
you're chasing what's going to feel like
when you hit your goal when you have a
million subscribers or a million in
revenue or whatever success looks like
to you
well what we're missing is the
Fulfillment part of it so something
wrong with chasing those goals there's
nothing wrong with having that caffeine
high that Sugar Rush that you know hey I
hit my goal amazing there's nothing
wrong with it but if that's all there is
you need the meal
right if that's all there is you're
never actually going to be happy because
those are just moments in time
that you're you get excited today if
that something happened and then you
might wait another month before the next
exciting thing happens we're just
Adrenaline Junkies that's what
entrepreneurs are a lot of entrepreneurs
just become Adrenaline Junkies chasing
the next High
that's not sustainable That's not
healthy and that's not ultimate
happiness
you have to pair it with the Fulfillment
when you can do both
that I'm I'm chasing these big goals
these Big Dreams or even something small
I can do right now to get excited and
pairing it with what I do matters this
is fulfilling to me this is going to
make a difference in somebody's life
that's where I think you have long-term
sustainable healthy forms of happiness
the good news is both of them you can
accomplish right now
at any point in time
you could choose to help somebody you
could choose to go serve somebody right
at any point in time it could be you
know helping those people put the
groceries in their car right they could
go go help them or take the shopping
cart and and put it away for them random
act of kindness it could be going to
somebody's YouTube comments and leaving
a nice message think about a creator
that you like to follow somebody else
that you subscribe to who maybe doesn't
have as big a following go leave a nice
message how long does it take you to do
right 18 seconds you just made a
difference in somebody's life
[Music]
responding to somebody who follows you
on Instagram and saying hey thank you
for following me on Instagram I really
appreciate you that's how I built my
Instagram following I'd be sitting here
at a Costco
individually messaging people who
followed me to say hey Rick hey Susan
hey Jennifer thank you so much for
following me I really appreciate you
thank you send next right seven seconds
eight seconds 15 seconds at a time
you can choose at any point to be happy
how did not procrastinate best way I
found is you create a calendar so you
create a calendar and you put in your
calendar the habits that will lead you
towards success right so you have ideas
for what you want to create amazing none
of that happens until you create into
actions right it's the actions and the
habits that you do every day that lead
you towards your dreams otherwise it
just remains hopes and dreams so this
would not be happening if it was on my
calendar but I had to schedule this in I
want to walk outside for three hours a
day great well when is that going to
start if I did not put in my calendar I
would not be out here doing this and so
step one is you create a calendar that
Maps your Ambitions that are the habits
that if you follow those habits you'll
move closer to your goals your business
goals your personal goals your
relationship goals your Finance goals
are you doing the work is it in your
calendar right step one and then step
two is you teach yourself that you do
what's in your calendar we're
eliminating the thought process behind
it this procrastination is your brain
gets in the way right your brain is
telling you oh I'll do it later I can't
do it now I'm not smart enough or I I
need to do some research first like your
brain gets in the way so the way the
shortcut the brain is you create the
calendar and then you do what's in your
calendar
so you create the calendar when you're
feeling bold and courageous and you come
with a new goal it's like so exciting
great don't just sit in that excitement
and not just go researching plop in your
calendar how you're going to keep this
consistently happening in your life so
that you don't just get this momentarily
burst of energy and then you fall back
down
right so you put it in your calendar how
you're going to sustain this action how
I got this how is that an event uh two
weeks ago and I got this idea that I'm
going to start walking outside and it
started off as two hours a day then
lastly became three hours a day this
week continuing three hours a day
it's great to get an idea how many times
you got an idea at an event or watching
a video you get some great idea awesome
if you just do it once it's not enough
how do you maintain the consistency how
do you turn into a habit don't wait for
you to feel motivated it has to go into
your calendar so I pop this into my
calendar and then when I wake up and I
look at my calendar I do it to my
calendar
so you eliminate the brain from the
process and therefore eliminating the
procrastination so you create your
calendar when you're feeling bold and
courageous and on top of the world and
Unstoppable
maybe like right now you're getting some
energy go put something in your calendar
and then when you wake up you do what's
in your calendar do those two things
it'll change your life there is always a
way there is always a way there is
always a way there is always a way there
is always a way when you feel stuck when
you feel hopeless when you feel like the
world is against you and you've got big
ambitious goals remind yourself there is
always a way there is always a way
entrepreneurship is always about how
resourceful you are instead of the lack
of resources this is where people get
caught up you wish you had more money
you wish you had a different education
you wish you had different parents you
wish you lived in a different country
you're so focused on the things that are
not going right in your life instead of
focusing on what can I do with what I do
have there is always a way wife has to
go shopping on filming day great I'll
film in the car with Timo hi Teemo high
five good boy
he's so cute uh business shuts down my
dance studio closes down because of
covet great Move online like there's
always a way I was telling my friend
Mark about
uh how I got the Honest Company for my
book your one word so I don't know three
four five years ago I don't know how
long ago how long ago when did Euro win
come out it doesn't matter
um I wanted to get the Honest Company
because they built their business around
their one word honesty and they were you
know 100 million dollar plus company
wanted to interview them there was only
one big problem I didn't know them I had
no connection in and I I wrote in and I
didn't hear back
and I really really wanted the company
so there's always a way remind yourself
there's always a way so what I did was I
wrote to TechCrunch and TechCrunch at
the time was the biggest you know blog
slash website slash news site for the
tech industry and I said hey I uh I
messaged the the managing editor who I
did not know either right just cold out
of the blue said hey I'm writing a book
and I'd love to do an interview with the
Honest Company
and if I did an interview with the
Honest Company would you publish it
we're going to talk about these topics
uh and he said yes
we just interviewed the managing editor
out of the blue and he said yes great
now I can go back to the Honest Company
and say Hey I want to do an interview
with you for my book and for TechCrunch
and that got me in the door
right and that then that led to me doing
the interview and flying to California
and meeting Christopher gavigan who's an
amazing human uh and doing the interview
and
getting my book done
and so I didn't know the Honest Company
I didn't know that crunch I had no
Connections in
but you remind yourself there's always a
way and that's how you do it you find a
way
what can you do with what you do have
right now how can you be a resource how
can you be an asset how can you help the
people around you so that you can move
closer to accomplishing your goals as
well so how do you do it you know it's
easy to say great Evan uh you don't
understand me I'm stuck in the situation
right now how do I get out of it
everybody's against me I tried a million
I tried everything I tried everything
and it's not working how do I get out of
it it's a couple things you need to do
number one if you are stuck kind of in
the middle of it if you are stuck
feeling overwhelmed feeling it's not
possible feeling
just you've tried everything and you're
gonna give up
step number one is you have to take a
break from where you are right now
go outside go for a walk breathe
meditate because when you're in when
you're in the lowest of the low
me saying be more resourceful there's
always a way you can't actually hear it
you're not ready for the message yet
because you're too low
this is why a lot of us when we're
trying to help other people the people
around us and telling them you're going
to make it you can be great they can't
hear it because they're too low so you
have to get them back to normal State
you have to get yourself back to a
normal state so that comes from some
getting outside your environment right
now go for a walk get some fresh air do
some breathing meditate pray whatever
you need to do to get back to a normal
state so you're not a depressed human
but you can actually be open and
receptive to a message it's
quit
it only counts
Cal a big dream a big ambition and you
want to chase it down and it doesn't
work out on the first try or the second
try the third try if you keep going
eventually you'll figure it out this is
the path of all successful entrepreneurs
like if you keep going you keep putting
one foot in front of the other
eventually it will work out is why a lot
of entrepreneurs will preach patience
because most people quit too soon most
people they overestimate what they can
get done in a short amount of time and
underestimate what they can get done
over a long amount of time and they just
quit too soon you don't allow enough
time for momentum to actually take hold
and so it's only really a failure if you
stop
people ask me about about my videos and
my YouTube channel and and there's a
couple angles on this the first is how
long it took me to get going if you look
at my uh my growth and my channel my
home page you can see how long it took
me to get going it took five years and I
still had seven thousand subscribers or
something like that and the only thing
that I had going for me was that I just
did not stop I I was introverted and shy
I still am I didn't know how to make
videos that was very uncomfortable in
front of the camera I was completely
embarrassed by my own stuff the first
350 videos I couldn't watch back
couldn't watch myself back I was too
critical on myself too embarrassed that
I was putting this out
um too hard on myself that I that it
wasn't good enough and that I wasn't
delivering value and just nitpicking
myself so many times on the videos that
I I just couldn't watch them back 350
videos public videos on my channel
before I was not just completely
embarrassed by myself and then 700
before I inspired myself like oh you
know what I'm like that was pretty good
I have one that I'm happy with after 700
public videos so most people just quit
too soon the only thing I had going for
me I didn't have the skills I didn't
have the personality I was not funny I
didn't have the editing capabilities I
didn't have the camera the technical
capabilities the only thing I had going
for me was that I kept going
I had the heart I wanted to serve and I
just kept going I just kept creating I
just kept making and now we're here you
know started from the bottom now we're
here that's now we're here but it took a
long time to get going and most people
who probably have more
natural abilities
more camera presence more humor more fun
uh they could have been way ahead of me
not that it's a competition but they
could have had success
but they didn't because they stopped
they quit self-confidence comes from
doing difficult things self-confidence
self-love self-respect it all comes from
deciding to do something difficult
here's what happens when when something
hard comes up and you find a reason why
you can't do it
it's too hard it's too difficult it's
too scary
most people will let you off the hook
the people around you will say yeah yeah
that's way too hard I mean the fact you
even thought about it was crazy
you let yourself off the hook
but then you realize
could have done it you know like that's
the worst feeling in the world that you
could have done something
but then you came up with an excuse as
to why you can't
and that will eat you up
and even if the world lets you off the
hook
recognize that they have lower standards
than you
recognize that the people who are giving
you that advice and padding on the back
and saying it's okay you don't need to
do it
they don't like their life either
they're stuck they're trapped
they're not pushing hard they're not
being aggressive for their goals they're
not tough either
and we're reinforcing that Comfort Loop
every day comfort you versus growth you
are in a fight there's a war going on
inside you comfort you versus growth you
comfort Evan birth is growth Evan every
day there's a fight there's a battle
there's a war going on and you need to
decide who's gonna win the fight
it's a daily thing and the more growth
you wins against comfort you the more
you start to grow the more you start to
hit your goals the more you start to
have an impact the more you start to
love yourself
[Music]
because again even if the world would
let you off the hook
you know it's just an excuse
I think most people think of it as a
giant step that you have to take to
build that self-confidence it's not I
think it's much more about the daily
battles with yourself that then builds
up to Major things just like you don't
go to the gym and lift 400 pounds you
start by lifting five pounds or ten
pounds or 20 pounds or 40 pounds
whatever it is that's how you start to
build the muscle it's much more about
the Daily building of the muscle to show
yourself who you are much more than the
one-off heroic moments you can get Grid
at almost any skill almost any skill
you could get great at if you wanted to
if you dedicated yourself to practicing
if you dedicated yourself to modeling
success if you dedicated yourself to
doing it you could get great at almost
any skill now
you know where people go with this is
the the extreme like well I I can't
become
you know seven footer in the NBA like
okay great if you're five two you know
you might not be able to be a seven foot
in the NBA right but but just think
about it think about your goals think
about your dreams think about where you
want to go
what you want to do is possible
stop looking at all the the rare
exceptions of how you can't do it and
instead focus on how you can
[Music]
where we struggle is because the things
that we need to get great at
we probably aren't very good at that
this is a really big deal for
entrepreneurs because you're probably
good at some things you're probably
naturally good at some things or you had
some training or your parents put you
into classes and you developed a skill
set at something but you may not
[Music]
we're good at things that we don't like
doing
you're probably really good at a lot of
things that you don't want to actually
now commit the rest of your life to
doing
and so this creates the Dilemma this
creates an entrepreneur's dilemma
we should name it something maybe it's
the entrepreneur's Dilemma where
you have two choices you either focus on
what you're good at that can get you
paid that can get you a job that can
maybe even have you start your business
you're good at it you can get paid doing
it but it is not something you enjoy and
the more you do it you Soul you slowly
start to lose your soul it slowly starts
to be life sucking for you like imagine
this thing that you're good at that you
don't like doing just imagine you close
your eyes you're daydreaming imagine
that you had to do this thing for the
next 40 Years of your life
how much would you hate your life if you
keep doing those things
so it's that you keep doing the things
that you're good at but you don't like
versus the things that you want to be
good at that you really love but right
now you suck at it
that's the hardest thing for people it's
like you want to get good at this other
thing that's where your passion is
that's where your heart is but you don't
have the skills yet and so a lot of
entrepreneurs where they quit this is
where a lot of you will quit you'll quit
you'll stop because you're not good at
it it's like oh wow I suck at it
and so I guess I'll never be good at it
and so then you don't do it where all
you need to do is flip it to say okay I
don't suck as a human
I don't I don't I'm not good at the
skill set yet but it can get good at it
how do I get good get good at it is by
practicing
when I first started making videos
everything is against me right if you
look at who I was where I came from my
personality my thought process
everything was against me for making
videos let me let me break it down let
me actually take you into the early days
of Evan Carmichael making YouTube videos
I am shy
I am introverted uh I don't like
disappointing people I have no need to
be famous you know I don't I don't like
the spotlight I actually would rather be
at the back of the room instead of you
know on stage
all of this doesn't sound good for
somebody who's
just then gonna go make videos turning
on the camera terrified me uh I'm
filming here in a parking lot right or
my wife is shopping at Costco there
um I would never be able to do this you
know there's people walking by this
would this would freak me out
I would say who's that who's that crazy
guy in the car doing that thing you know
on paper I guess everything looked like
it was against me I made a video
because I had this idea to make a video
because I'm a visual learner
I think your purpose comes from your
pain
I struggled so much as an entrepreneur I
wanted to make the road a little bit
easier for other entrepreneurs
and so I made one video
and it was it was not the greatest
experience
I was terrified I was sitting down I was
in a suit I was nervous I was memorizing
a script because I was so worried that I
was gonna say the wrong words and people
wouldn't like my video they can go back
and watch the first one I did on Walt
Disney and it took a day or whatever to
make this one short video and I'm not
even on camera for most of it most of it
is me doing an audio because I could I
could read it I wanted to read the
script I had the perfect script
and there was b-roll on top of it there
was very little of me actually on camera
but even those few lines I had on camera
was terrified and I was trying to
memorize and I was sweating and it's
funny sitting down in the suit all that
was hilarious I wasn't very good at it
I wasn't very good at it but there was
something about it that I just liked
I liked it I liked the idea none of it
made sense right again there was no
option to be YouTube famous nobody was
YouTube famous uh in in education in
2009 when I first started it didn't
exist
and my personality of being introverted
chai all that did not lend itself well
to being uh a personality
but for some reason even everything was
seemingly against me on paper I just I
liked it
and I wasn't very good at it but I
thought you know what I can get better
I'm gonna keep doing this thing
and it took me
you could see my stats and I posted off
into to my Instagram once a month it's
an update of how my channel is doing
from the first video that I posted it
took five years to get to 9 000
subscribers
five years to get the 9 000 subscribers
a lot of you guys are already way ahead
of that after your first year of just
making content
you're already ahead
and then I went five years again from
the 9000 to 2 million
see there's a person next to me right
now
try to film her this would freak me out
I'm gonna be filming here making a video
with this person's right next to me how
he should judge me what is she thinking
what is she doing you know I get super
distracted I wouldn't be able to film
the content
so it took me 350 videos until I wasn't
completely embarrassed by myself
embarrassed like I couldn't watch back
my own videos they were too painful to
watch I would look at it I would judge
myself I would criticize myself I would
I would say man you're still not very
good I would find a million things that
was wrong with the video just so many so
many things that
I was not happy with
350 public videos guys 350 and then I
took 700 videos until I inspired myself
until I watched it back I said man I'm
you know what this I I'm starting to get
decent at this you know there's
something there maybe maybe I have a
future here
700 public videos later it's crazy so
what what kept me through it what kept
me
consistent how did I keep going because
the mission yes of of wanting to help
serve entrepreneurs but also I liked I
liked it I liked the process of doing it
there was something again even though it
didn't make sense
for someone like me to do it I liked it
it was fun and so I kept going and you
know now we're
over 10 000 videos later still making
content still doing it and not burning
out because I like the process if you
love what you're doing you're not going
to burn out as entrepreneurs we're
Mission driven right you want to solve a
big problem you want to make a huge
change in the world so remind yourself
of what the mission is and how grateful
you are to be on this path even if
you're not where you want to be yet
you're not doing what you want to do
fully yet but you never are there you
never when you hit that goal you you
want a bigger goal I think that's great
so you're on your journey
and you're much more fulfilled on that
Journey than you used to be compared to
who you used to be
compare your life to where you were five
years ago or ten years ago
the awareness education you've gone
through the the purpose the heart that
you've now discovered and tapped into on
a deeper level
for me I'd be thinking about
helping entrepreneurs
I get to every day wake up and help
entrepreneurs I get to make videos I get
to make content I get to influence
people I get to I get to try to
help 18 year old Evans out there who's
struggling with their first business
right
for you what's your big mission
and how can you tap into it and feel it
and it may not have to take too long to
do it but just close your eyes and
actually feel that you touch somebody's
life
again it may not be the scale that you
want it's never the scale you want but
you touch somebody's life
if one person left a comment on your
video one person left a thumbs up on
your post you touch one person's life
tap into what that feels like
that you had a meaningful impact on them
today I
beliefs that I read every morning every
single morning I have it written on my
computer I pop it up and these are the
lists of beliefs and values that I want
to remind myself of that I want to live
today and every day and I find that
reminding myself of it in the morning
helps make sure that I actually follow
through on it during the day and so one
of those things that I read to myself
every morning is that work is play one
of the beliefs that I want to espouse on
a daily basis is that work is play that
work isn't just work that work isn't a
place to go and die and work isn't a
place to go and struggle and yes work is
a lot of hard work right work is a lot
of a grind work is a lot of getting
stuff done and checking a lot of things
off the list right you want to be
productive and feel like you're creating
meaningful value in the world today but
it doesn't have to suck like work can be
fun and it's partly enjoying the work
having passion for what you're doing
right doing something that you feel is
Meaningful but also just having fun with
it and so if I look at some of the
things that I do you know in our office
environment I had Alex and Lily over and
they started breaking out into a song
you're about gently down the stream
and in the morning when I'm making
videos for my my book you'll see me on
Snapchat with you know rabbit ears or
raccoon ears or some fun filter on it
and fun is different to each person
right I'm not the guy who's going to be
out cracking jokes that's maybe more
Alex's style but the point is that
you're doing the things that you can
express your creativity through that you
are having fun with if you are on your
way to your office whether your office
is your basement or your home office or
natural office where you have your
employees and team members if you're on
your way to go and do work
and you are dreading it like oh another
day and it's like it feels like the
world is beating you down you're not
going to create great work like if you
feel like you have to just plow through
a whole bunch of crap every day
it's not gonna feel fun you're not going
to create an amazing experience and so
if you can approach it with how can I
have fun today it's just asking that
question how can I make this fun it's
not by taking breaks right it's not by
doing something in between to break up
the crap right it's not okay I'm gonna
I'm gonna grind through this for two
hours and then I'm gonna I'm gonna take
a celebration and go grab a coffee and
then come back and I'm going to grind
out some more it's like how can you make
the grind fun
how can you inject fun into the actual
process so that you are enjoying the
process because you can get to that
point it's not that every single minute
of every day is going to be amazing but
if you get to that point where work is
play where work is fun you're not just
going to have more fun but it's going to
show in the result as well it's going to
show in what you create you're going to
create better things it's going to add
more value it's going to help you grow
your business much more than if you go
to work every day feeling like the world
is crushing you down my question is
marketing last year I did an online
somatic breath work and I didn't really
know how to Market and I only have one
person show up people don't know who I
am yet so you have any tips on how to
Market in person for Live Events and
online so the fastest way if you want to
fill it up is through Partnerships
unless you've got a big ad budget that
you're going to start spending it's
Partnerships whose space are you doing
it out of the gym I go to can you put
flyers up in the gym yeah I can the
people who are going to come to your
event they're paying you to come to the
workshop yes could the gym help promote
it and take a cut yeah I'm sure I can
work with my yeah they email it to their
list then they get a commission okay
yeah maybe you're gonna need a
commission maybe they'll just do it for
you yeah can you go and be at the front
of the gym for the week before and talk
to people as they come in and have
flyers and share about the workshop that
you have coming up have an announcement
board you can put something up on it's
like how can we use the location to help
promote because there's foot traffic
coming in every day because people
coming to the gym every day how can we
help get our message to them and
incentivize the gym maybe they do it
because they just love you maybe they do
it because you're you're renting space
maybe they do because they're making a
cut all of the instructors all of the
the people who are you know personal
trainers there getting to know them so
that they're saying in the class
potentially that you've got this thing
coming up so that's the easiest one next
you go to all of your the local media
the local newspaper the local Facebook
groups the local whatever and get to
know the reporters so you're in Eureka
California yeah great yeah like there's
some newspaper for Eureka California
that that
you know you and I saw you trying to get
into the LA Times
you're trying to get into the Eureka
newspaper okay it's a lot easier yeah so
what reporter is talking about the
events in Eureka right now get to know
her or him and let them know that you've
got because you're ideally this is an
ongoing thing it's not just this one
event yeah a weekly event
right so build up those connections help
that negative voice inside your head
that's telling you that you suck and you
can't do it that's not your voice
that's not actually your voice that's
not you telling yourself that you suck
that voice was planted there that voice
was put there by somebody else in your
life and probably early on growing up
telling you that you can't do something
you were not born you didn't come out of
the womb and say I suck I can't do
anything no you're playing you're
experimenting you're finding Joy you're
laughing you're you're doing it
and then along the way people tell you
that you can't do it that you should
stop that you should quit that it's not
gonna work out that you can't do it and
we've been so conditioned around that
that we take it on and we think it's our
voice
when you come up with an idea right
just Workshop this you come up with an
idea it's like oh I'm gonna I'm gonna go
I'm gonna write a book I'm gonna start a
YouTube channel I'm gonna launch his
business I'm going to whatever you come
up with your your bucket list your your
dream life your vision board you come
with a list of ideas things that you
think that you want to do things that
you
feel confident that you'd love to create
for yourself right okay what happens the
next day the next day
it's not even telling our friends you
know I think we we blame our friends and
say well we tell our friends and they're
going to be negative and and they they
they crap on our idea and so we don't do
it well before that happens we crap on
our own ideas right you look at that
list the next day and say I can't do
that who who
was I yesterday this crazy person that I
used to be yesterday who thought I could
do that
it's ourselves telling ourselves that we
suck but the problem is we've taken on
that voice and we think that it's us
that's not your voice that is not your
voice telling you that you suck that is
somebody else's voice that was planted
in your head that has been conditioned
to be there that we're so used to being
there that we have taken on as our voice
it has become your identity but it was
not your voice it was put there it was a
seed that was planted that has been
grown over time and you need to rip that
weed out
that is not your voice
you do not think that you suck
it's other people with low expectations
who hate their own lives who at some
point went and tried something that did
not work out for their life and now
nobody around them can have success
because it makes them look and feel bad
and so they spend their time ripping
other people down and apart
that's who planted that weed in your
head that might hit pretty hard I hope
it does because when that happened when
if you can actually
digest that
what ends up happening is you think oh
who whose voice is that who's whose
voice is in my head and that's great
awareness to know that it's not your
voice and then to identify whose voice
it is who told you these things who made
you feel this way growing up
and if you think about who that person
is if you can actually picture somebody
oh that was Uncle Joe or oh that was my
grade three teacher oh or that was my
you know the bully at school whoever
that person was now think about okay
it's that person's voice not you that's
already incredibly liberating
but then two do you want to live that
person's life like think about that
person probably they're not living a
great life they're not hitting their
potential they're not even happy with
what they're doing if somebody's
spending their day tearing other people
down what kind of painful life does that
person have to have when they go home
you don't want their life
if you don't want their life then you
definitely don't want their voice in
your head anymore hopefully that creates
an aha moment for you that starts to
actually shift things because we've been
so conditioned to listen to that voice
that we don't recognize that we actually
have a choice to rip it out
and start to listen to our own voice I
would have been the guy who 10 years ago
would have thought that's not possible
for me I'm just introverted shy kid who
just is not a type A personality and
doesn't like networking and will never
meet these people so
step one
consume their content even if you never
meet these people just having them
around you daily allows you to start to
shift and start to think like them
allows you to start to adopt their
mindset because they're saying things
that are different than the people in
your life
John astraff is saying something
different than your parents right he's
thinking a different way than your
friends he's thinking on a higher level
than a lot of the people probably in
your life right now
and so the more that you're around that
virtually by watching videos even if you
never meet him the more you start to
think bigger to have more ambition to
believe that it's possible so part of
your daily routine must must must be
to consume the content of the people who
inspire you to want to be bigger that's
why I make this espresso videos why I
make all of my content on all of my
channels but if it's not my videos if
it's books if it's podcasts
something it's got to be daily though
just like you brush your teeth daily you
need to inject
positivity and belief daily from people
who are doing more than you right your
brushing teeth helps you with your
dental hygiene we need to work on our
mental hygiene it's really important
because the the mental hygiene will take
care of itself in a negative way based
off your current environment
if you are if you are just constantly
battling negativity around you or
small-mindedness around you and there's
nothing that comes into your life that
feeds you with hope and positivity and
inspiration and the sense that you could
do more if there's nothing in that in
your life right now then you won't go
off and do it and so step one is to just
be around the content every single day
in micro doses every single day my new
routine right now is I go for a walk in
the morning and it's about 40 to 45
minutes in the morning and I I watch my
own videos I watch my top 10 videos
while I go for the walk so this morning
I was watching uh Lewis Howes video and
a garyvee video that I made for my
channel and every time I do it I pick up
something new it it's a fantastic way to
start my day if you could start your day
every day with garyvee or Lewis Howes or
John assarath or Oprah or Elon Musk or
whoever your life will change
it's why I do these espresso videos I
want to give you the shot event special
every morning your life will change if
you start your day every day with the
people who inspire you they will pull
you up and you don't notice it on a
day-to-day basis but if you look back a
week a month three months six months a
year if you did it every day for a year
holy cow you will be a totally different
person I think you're a tree and I wrote
about this in in my book built to serve
I think you're a tree what does a tree
do a tree Breeze in the carbon dioxide
which
too much of for humans is poison we
breathe the trees will breathe it in
they'll eat it they'll grow from it and
it'll spit out oxygen positivity for the
world I see that as part of our role as
leaders and as entrepreneurs is to eat
other people's negativity grow from it
get better from it and then spit out
more positivity more oxygen for the
world ultimately the people who are
negative in your life you have an
ability to influence them you have an
ability to help them see the positive
Road not through your
advice but through your actions by you
going off and doing your thing will
inspire other people to want to change
their life as well whoever is more
confident wins and when you're around
really negative people if you are
doubting your positivity they're gonna
win they're gonna drag you down
But ultimately the goal is to get so
positive so optimistic so
so happy that you pull them up
that you're more positive you're more
certain in your positivity than they are
certain in their negativity and you pull
them towards making a better life
decision try to be a person of value
being a person of value means what does
this person care about and how can you
help support it so if you're trying to
be a person of value to me what am I
what do I care about right now you know
the easiest thing to do is look at my
Instagram bio look at my Twitter bio
look at the things that I'm promoting
right now right now if uh right now I'm
talking about build to serve a lot it's
still something I care deeply about
right now I'm talking about movement
makers I'm talking about brand lytics
these are the programs that I'm
launching that I care a lot about so how
can you help me with that
what is John astraff watching go look at
his Instagram bio his Twitter bio what
is he promoting right now that's what he
cares about right now to be a person of
value you want to be the person's chief
goal officer what do they need right now
what are they promoting right now what
are their goals right now and then
finding some way to help them even if
it's just being the best person in the
comments
right I have an amazing community that
you guys are amazing
it's what makes me want to keep making
content is because of how fantastic you
guys are and there are some people who
watch the videos and then never leave
any any comments leave comments guys
there are some people who watch the
video and leave a comment and then there
are the special few who watch your video
leave a comment but then we'll also
comment on the other comments not in a
promotional way not just saying hey
check out my new channel I've worked
really hard on it let me know sub for
sub but in uh in a encouraging positive
optimistic way in just trying to cheer
the other people on and supporting them
those people are extra special and there
are there are some people who
I would do the best that I could to try
to support them I'll get hit up every
day with different promotional
opportunities hey Evan can you link this
up can you shout me out can you check
out my business plan and it's usually I
know because I don't even know who you
are
but there are other people who have
brought so much value to my community
that I would I would do my very best to
try to help them because of how much
they've helped me even though they may
not have ever bought anything that I've
done just because they were so valuable
in the community
right so that's your goal your goal
is to be a person of value to be the
chief goal officer and then be a person
of value to them and their community so
they start to recognize you for too many
of us there's no deadline when's the
deadline on your dreams when's the
deadline to make your content what's the
deadline to actually execute things for
most of us there's no deadline you don't
have a deadline and so because you don't
have the deadline you allow yourself to
procrastinate and to and to Tinker on to
make things perfect and to never release
because there's no deadline it doesn't
matter enough
when I'm making videos I have to make a
certain number of videos every week for
my channels and there's a deadline I
have to get them done today they have to
get done today because tomorrow I'm
doing something else and the next day
I'm doing something else and I'm not
touching my YouTube content again until
next Tuesday
so if I don't get it done today then my
team doesn't have content to go off and
create for the channels and then I'm
disappointing you
and it's been I don't know seven or
eight years since we haven't not since
we have not haven't not since we have
not uploaded a video on one of our
channels
years it's been years
of consistency and that's
how you start to build the machine
because there's a deadline because it
matters because it's important today I'm
here making videos for you because
that's part of my routine
you know I'm recording this on a Tuesday
every Tuesday I make videos every
Tuesday I make videos every Tuesday I
make videos every Tuesday I make videos
I've made videos
feeling sick I've made videos with no
voice and I held up signs I made videos
with a concussion and a broken neck I
make videos that's the difference
between an achiever and a high achiever
is that you show up when everybody else
would give you a break when everybody
else would say take it easy when
everybody else would say you're pushing
too hard everybody else says you're too
obsessed
you say no I'm committed to my goals I
committed to making this happen
because you are what you consistently do
we tend to try to over correct things if
you have a goal of eating a certain
number of calories or sticking to a
certain weight and you go and you binge
one day we tend to try to over correct
to say that's it I'm going on a 24-hour
fast
you know I'm just not going to eat
anything for 24 hours or if your
business you let yourself down you don't
deliver you don't promise you don't
follow through on the Promises you say
you're going to make videos for YouTube
and then you don't do it and then the
next day you wake up say I'm done with
that I'm going to make 80 videos today
or whatever the number would be we tend
to try to do too much in the short run
and that's not where the gains are made
right you could go to the gym and have
an amazing session
but if you're not consistently showing
up to the gym you're not going to get
the results that you want same thing for
the gym of Life the gym of business the
gym of of your mindset it's what you do
consistently every single day and that
can sometimes be boring
and that can sometimes be that you're
you're chasing the wrong thing you're
doing somebody else's routine instead of
your own but if you want to be a high
achiever if you want to show up
for yourself for your family for the
people around you for your customers the
people who know you can serve you want
to show up as your best self every day
for them the key is that you stick to
your habits have a reminder system in
your life constantly what are the things
because you're feeling it right now
hopefully if you're watching you're
feeling it right now you're feeling
excited right now you're gonna make a
change right now and then tomorrow
you're going to fall back to who you
used to be so what what do you need in
your environment what do you need in
your habits and your daily routines to
remind you you need to remind your
system so it can become more automatic
that it doesn't rely on your self-will
and your discipline constantly that it
gets introduced to you constantly
whether that's
uh YouTube videos why hey espresso five
days a week every morning I'm here let's
go here's a new video for you uh if it's
Ed mylett's Channel or Tony Robbins
Channel or or Oprah Winfrey's videos
like whoever or if his books or podcasts
if it's your physical environment if
it's uh morning intention like just
figure it out for yourself
and schedule it in
schedule in the reminders
scheduling the intentionality so that
this doesn't just become a one-off
moment but that it's a daily reminder
it's a daily consistency it's daily
momentum because you need that
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Tom bill you
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there one reframe your
thinking around AI do not see it as the
enemy see it as a tool you're not going
to be replaced by AI at least not yet
you're going to be replaced by a human
using AI